do you have advice for young people
today
aside from playing lots of video games
uh you know high schoolers
college students thinking about their
career thinking about life
well we no longer live in a world where
you get one skill set you do it for
40 years and retire i mean that that
ship has sailed a long time ago
so learn how to learn and learn an
appreciation and love for learning
so that's the first thing you know josh
waitzkins wrote this beautiful book the
art of learning if you ever read it yeah
stuff like that uh so good study skills
you know
slip box notes these things what was it
um
settle casting or whatever yeah there's
a lot of little techniques that you can
pick up along the way
and basically to teach you how to
process lots of information very quickly
retain it and then decide what's useful
to you for that moment
the second thing is do not undervalue eq
emotional intelligence we we've lived
for a long time in a society where iq
was dominant it's like how smart you are
excuses
everything else you could be a horrible
human being but he's a really bright guy
right the mathematician or
physicist
we now live in a world where the balance
is far more important
you have to be smart but you also have
to be a nice guy
and don't undervalue that so learn
things like closed circuit communication
and active listening
these skill sets will always pay
enormous dividends
along the way third remember that you
judge for the things that you have and
what you do
with those things you know if you have
very little you still have to do
something whether you have a lot you
have to do even more
so learn how to give and do that early
on
learn how to give back volunteerism
charity mentoring these types of things
those are so incredibly valuable to a
person's development the people that you
mentored in the academic world you learn
this you have graduate students
they one day will be professors and it
might just so happen they might eclipse
you
remember gauss had a doctoral advisor
never forget that you know and so did
feynman
make sure that you mentor people you
give back and you learn how to learn and
you learn how to teach
super important for your development as
a person now you'll notice all those
things are
agnostic to whatever domain you happen
to have chosen you could be in medicine
or law or technology whatever
that's your fancy whatever your passion
happens to be
and don't conflate your earning in your
career if people
try to keep putting these things
together they're increasingly becoming
decoupled there's a lot of cases where
people do their passions and they do it
for free or you know for
sustenance but then they have something
else they do on the side to also augment
or supplement their income
it's probably best that way when you
complete the two you tend to get burnt
out terribly you see this a lot with
musicians or other people
they just they want to make music but
they have to tour or whatever because i
got to pay bills
stuff like that happens other than that
i mean i i'm not a guru i'm not in any
particular
position dude you showed up in a robe
which i thought was kind of weird
and you had a crown and you kept calling
yourself king
of the rats and that was in a robe that
was a yukata
okay thank you for clarifying wait
audience he's joking
read it i heard somebody's going to
write blog posts
charles hoskinson walks and walks around
with a crown
you